there's an ancient parable about a
farmer who lost his horse and neighbors
came over to say oh that's too bad
and the farmer said good or bad hard to
say days later the horse returns and
brings with it seven wild horses and
neighbors come over to say oh that's so
good and the farmer just shrugs and says
good or bad hard to say the next day the
farmer's son rides one of the wild
horses is thrown off and breaks his leg
and the neighbors say oh that's terrible
luck and the farmer says could are bad
hard to say
eventually officers come knocking on
people's doors looking for men to draft
for an army and they see the farmer son
in his leg and they pass him by
and neighbors say oh that's great luck
and the farmer says good or bad hard to
say I first heard this story 20 years
ago and I have since applied at a
hundred times didn't get the job I
wanted good or bad hard to say got the
job I wanted good or bad hard to say to
me the story is not about looking on the
bright side or waiting to see how things
turn out it's about how eager we can be
to label a situation to put concrete
around it by judging it but reality is
much more fluid and good and bad are
often incomplete stories that we tell
ourselves the parable has been my
warning that by gripping tightly to the
story of good or bad I closed down my
ability to truly see a situation I learn
more when I proceed and loosen my grip
and proceed openly with curiosity and
wonder but seven years ago when I was
pregnant with my first child I
completely forgot this lesson I believed
I knew wholeheartedly what was good when
it came to having kids I thought that
good was some version of a superbaby
some ultra healthy human who possessed
not a single flaw and would practically
wear a cape flying into her superhero
future
I took DHA pills to ensure that my baby
had a super high functioning super smart
brain and I ate mostly organic food and
I trained for a medication free labor
and I did many other things because I
thought these things would help me make
not just a good baby but the best baby
possible when my daughter Fiona was born
she weighed 4 pounds 12 ounces or 2.15
kilograms the pediatrician said there
were only two possible explanations for
her tiny size either
he said it's bad seed or it's bad soil
and I wasn't so tired from labor to lose
the thread of his logic my newborn
according to the doctor was a bad plant
eventually I learned that my daughter
had an ultra rare chromosomal condition
called Wolfe Hirshhorn syndrome she was
missing a chunk of her fourth chromosome
and although my daughter was good she
was alive and she had brand new baby
skin and the most aware onyx eyes I also
learned that people with her syndrome
have significant developmental delays
and disabilities some never learned to
walk or talk I did not have the
equanimity of the farmer the situation
looked unequivocally bad to me but
here's where the parable is so useful
because four weeks after her diagnosis I
felt gripped by despair locked in the
story that all of this was tragic
reality though thankfully is much more
fluid and it has much more to teach as I
started to getting to know this
mysterious person who was my kid my
fixed tight story of tragedy loosened it
turned out my girl loved reggae and she
would smirk when my husband would bounce
her tiny body up and down to the rhythm
her onyx eyes eventually turned the most
stunning Lake Tahoe blue and she loved
using them to gaze intently into other
people's eyes at five months old she
could not hold her head up like other
babies but she could hold this deep
intent eye contact one friend said she's
the most aware baby I've ever seen but
where I saw the gift of her calm
attentive presence an occupational
therapist who came over to our house to
work with Fiona saw a child who is
neurologically dull she was this
therapist was especially disappointed
that Fiona wasn't rolling over yet and
so she told me we needed to wake her
neurology up one day she leaned over my
daughter's body took her tiny shoulders
jostle her and said wake up wake up we
had a few therapists visit our house
that first year and they usually focused
on what they thought was bad about my
kid I was really happy when Fiona
started using her right hand to bully a
dangling stuffed sheep but the therapist
was fixated on my child's left hand
Fiona had a tendency not to use this
hand very often and she would cross the
fingers on that hand so the therapist
said we should devise a splint which
would rob my kid of the ability to
actually use those fingers but it would
least forced them into some position
that looked normal in that first year I
was starting to realize a few things one
ancient parables aside my kid had some
bad therapists too I had a choice like a
person offered to swallow a red pill or
a blue pill I could choose to see my
daughter's differences as bad I could
strive toward the goal that her
therapists called you'd never know they
loved to pat themselves on the back when
they could say about a kid you'd never
know he was delayed or autistic or
different I could believe that the good
path was the path that erased as many
differences as possible of course this
would have been a disastrous a pursuit
because at the cellular level
my daughter had rare blueprints she
wasn't designed to be like other people
she would lead a rare life so I had
another choice I could drop my story
neurological differences and
developmental delays and disabilities
was bad which means I could also drop my
story that a more able-bodied life was
better I could release my cultural
biases about what made a life good or
bad and simply watched my daughter's
life as it unfolded with openness and
curiosity one afternoon she was lying on
her back and she arched her back on the
carpet stuck her tongue out of the side
of her mouth and managed to torque her
body over onto her belly then she tipped
over and rolled back onto her back and
once there she managed to do it all over
again
rolling and wiggling her 12-pound self
under a coffee table at first I thought
she'd gotten stuck there but then I saw
her reaching for something that her I
had been on all along a black electric
cord she was a year old other babies her
aged were for sure pulling up to stand
and toddling around some of them my kid
- some my kids situation looked bad a
one-year-old who could only roll but
screw that my kid was enjoying the new
limber freedom of mobility I rejoiced
then again what I watched that afternoon
was a baby yanking on an electric cord
so you know good or bad hard to say I
started seeing that when I released my
gripped about what made a life good or
bad I could watch my daughter's life
unfold and see what it was it was
beautiful it was complicated
joyful hard in other words just another
expression of the human experience
eventually my family and I moved to a
new state in America and we got lucky
with a brand new batch of therapists
they didn't focus on all that was wrong
with my kid they didn't see her
differences as problems to fix they
acknowledged her limitations but they
also saw her strengths and they
celebrated her for who she was
their goal wasn't to make Fiona as
normal as possible their goal was simply
to help her be as independent as
possible so that she could fulfill her
potential however that looked for her
but the culture at large does not take
this open attitude about disabilities we
call congenital differences birth
defects as though human beings were
objects on a factory line we might offer
pitying expressions when we learn that a
colleague had a baby with Down syndrome
we hail a blockbuster film about a
suicidal wheelchair user despite the
fact that actual wheelchair users tell
us that stereotype is unfair and
damaging and sometimes our medical
institutions decide what lives are not
worth living such as the case with
Amelia Rivera a girl with my daughter's
same syndrome in 2012 a famous American
Children's Hospital initially denied
Amelia the right to a life-saving kidney
transplant because according to their
form as it said she was mentally
this is the way that the story
of disabilities as bad manifests in a
culture but there's a surprisingly
insidious counter story the story
especially that people with intellectual
disabilities are good because they are
here to teach us something magical or
they are inherently angelic and always
sweet you have heard this ablest trope
before the boy with Down syndrome who's
one of God's special children or the
girl with the walker and the
communication device who's a precious
little angel this story rears its head
in my daughter's life around
Christmastime when certain people get
positively giddy at the thought of
seeing her in an angel's wings and a
halo at the pageant the insinuation is
that these people don't experience the
sticky complexities of being human and
although at times especially as a baby
my daughter has in fact looked angelic
she has grown into the type of kid who
does the rascally things that any other
kid does such as when she at age 4
shoved her two-year-old
sister my girl deserves the right to
annoy the hell out of you like any other
kid would we label a person tragic or
angelic bad or good we robbed them of
their humanity along with not only the
messiness and complexity that that title
brings but the rights and dignities as
well my girl does not exist to teach me
things or any of us things but she has
indeed taught me number one how many
mozzarella cheese sticks a 22 pound
human being can consume in one day which
is five for the record and two the gift
of questioning my cultures beliefs about
what makes a life good and what makes
life bad if you had told me six years
ago that my daughter would sometimes use
an iPad app to communicate I might have
thought that was sad but now I recall
the first day I handed Fiona her iPad
loaded with a thousand words each
represented by a tiny little icon or a
little square on her iPad app and I
recall how bold and hopeful it felt even
as some of her therapists said that my
expectations were way too high that she
would never be able to hit those tiny
targets and I recall watching in awe as
she gradually learned to flex her little
thumb and hit the buttons to say words
she loved like reggae and cheese and a
hundred other words she loved that her
mouth couldn't yet say and then we had
to teach her less fun words prepositions
words like of and on and in and we
worked on this for a few weeks and then
I recall sitting in a dining room table
with many relatives and apropos of
absolutely nothing Fiona used her iPad
app to say poop in toilet good or bad
hard to say my kid is human that's all
and that is a lot thank you
[Applause]
[Music]